volvemos con ustedes para más noticias
aquí en Francia 24 Mi nombre es Ángela
Gómez el 26 de septiembre de 2017 desde
Bogotá France 24 lanzó su versión en
español el canal decidió instalar su
redacción hispanohablante en el corazón
de América Latina para estar muy cerca
de su principal audiencia Franz 24 en
español Reporta a diario sobre la
actualidad latinoamericana e
internacional con una mirada francesa
fue una información
[Música]
más de 70 periodistas jóvenes y
Versátiles que vienen de América Latina
Francia y Europa componen la redacción
del Canal
y a la redacción forman un equipo que
tiene sus ojos en la región y en el
resto del mundo
a través de una red de más de 40
corresponsales confirmando las
expectativas France 24 en español ha
sido muy bien recibida en América Latina
de misión de Europa
a lo largo de estos años el canal ha
permitido duplicar la distribución de
France 24 en la región
Santiago
un verdadero puente entre Francia y
América Latina France 24 en español
ayuda a enriquecer las ofertas de
contenido de las antenas francesa
inglesa y árabe de la cadena contribuye
a las promoción y difusión de los
valores franceses en los 180 países
donde se emite france24